if you didn't click off in the first two
seconds then well done this video might
just save you over two hundred thousand
dollars what's going on guys my name's
David Thomas I'm a Redford architect
here in Western Australia and this is an
urgent warning for anybody purchasing a
land or property on realestate.com
firstly the website is phenomenal and
the resources it provides are excellent
but it does limit it ever so slightly
you're relying on the information
provided by the agents to make sure
you're completely informed and I can
guarantee you not every single listing
provides you with the truth so let's get
the largest cost saving out of the way
is your property in a Bushfire Zone if
it isn't well you're lucky but if it is
you could be spending an extra two
hundred thousand dollars plus just to
make sure that new home complies to the
current standards so how do you find out
well if they aren't already providing
you with this information in the
description of the listing there are a
number of ways you can quickly find out
the easiest one is free you can jump
onto the defense website I'll leave a
link down below and search your property
address if it falls into the pink Cloud
then it is in a Bushfire Zone and you're
going to have to get a Bushfire
assessment done any property in a
Bushfire Zone immediately will cost you
a couple thousand dollars more just to
make sure it complies however if it
falls in a flame Zone which is basically
in the middle of the forest it could
cost you up to 277
000 more than you originally anticipated
another way to find out is by
conditioning a Bushfire attack level
assessment prior to the purchase of the
property yes you can go out you can
condition the sale of it you can request
that a Bushfire assessor come out
perform an initial analysis of that site
and make sure it isn't in one of those
higher end flame zones now don't be
fearful about Bushfire zones because
they are more common than you think as
long as it's battle 29 or below you're
more than likely going to be able to
achieve whatever you had in your mind
however if it's about 40 or about FZ you
may need a professional opinion before
you purchase this property moving on to
the Goldilocks Theory essentially your
house could be too hot or too cold for a
simple fact that it's facing the wrong
way easiest way you can determine if a
block is going to be suitable for a
solar passive design or just generally
speaking a good architectural practices
design is in the southern hemisphere at
least that the longest side of your
property faces North now it could be a
jar a little bit it could be Northeast
it could be Northwest either way it
should be facing predominantly North in
the overall grand scheme things if it's
facing south and all of your views are
South well then you're going to either
have to overcompensate with heating and
cooling which is going to increase the
cost of your ownership across this
lifetime or you're going to have to
decrease the glazing which may not be
exactly what you're looking for because
you might be looking at the beautiful
ocean we've all heard of the saying love
thy neighbor but when it comes to buying
property on realestate.com.u generally
speaking they will tell you what your
property is and what that property has
owned they don't care about your
neighbors and they're not worried about
them so if you're not paying attention
and if you're not researching your
neighbors you could be left with a
skyscraper next to you in a number of
years so for instance we've had projects
where our clients have gone ahead and
purchased an R40 project which is a
pretty typical zoning in Western
Australia this R40 zoning generally
allows them to do about a two or three
story development depending on the size
of the site and how it actually Contours
and moves what they don't normally pay
attention to is what the neighbor is
owned sometimes especially in the CBD it
could be your direct neighbor or it
could be your neighbor two or three
doors down that is allowed to build r100
so again just talking in general terms
they could be allowed to build six
stories next to you completely
overshadowing your project and ruining
the quality of your life now is this
legal absolutely they're allowed to
build this on their property and they
are allowed to comply with planning
regulations so you need to be cautious
when buying a property that the
neighbors are also zoned at the exact
same thing as you so that you're not
going to be overpowered and overshadowed
in the future typically zonings are
available years and years and years in
advance so it doesn't sneak up on you
and if you haven't done your research
you might just devalue property and lose
money if you're in a leafy green
neighborhood you probably love those
leafy green trees but you're not paying
attention to them when you're buying a
property you're going this is a
beautiful Street it is covered in trees
it is exactly what the neighborhood
needs but what you need to be paying
attention to is the exact location of
that Verge Tree on your particular Verge
because let's say you have a small
narrow lot maybe it's only about 10
meters wide you might have one two or
even three Verge trees that you may or
may not be allowed to remove or relocate
so now all of a sudden your grand plans
are building this beautiful home with a
driveway on this particular side and all
of the norm light coming into your
living rooms has been completely gutted
because the council may not allow you to
relocate this tree and you have to
meander in between some very old
beautiful trees just to get to your
house no this isn't going to cost you
any more to build on but it will be
something that you're not paying
attention to and it isn't highlighted on
realestate.com so jump on Google Maps
open up street view make sure you
understand that if there is Verge trees
and where the Verge trees are on your
property and if it's outdated data go
for a drive the time and money spent
going to this property in inspecting it
looking at it to make sure it isn't the
wrong project for you could save you a
hell of a lot of headaches my last
suggestion for you to be mindful of When
shopping on realestate.com.eu is water
now you may be thinking what the hell
but water is your worst nightmare during
construction first of all you don't want
to be starting a project in the winter
season it makes it a lot more
challenging but more importantly you
don't want to be digging indeed watering
a project this could make or break the
entire project and send you completely
broke so if you're looking at a property
or real estate.com.eu that is very close
to water a water body beta River the
ocean or anything in between make sure
you understand where the water table
below that site lies because for
instance if you're looking to build a
basement an underground garage or
anything that requires digging out the
land throwing out that soil and then
building it may or may not be the new
project when you're close to a body of
water the natural water table Rises and
fall for the seasons and sometimes at
its worst case it could only be a couple
meters below the surface level so if
you're going to dig out three to five
meters of that site you're going to be
trying to pump out thousands and
thousands and thousands of liters of
water that has to be stored somewhere
that has to be discharged properly and
it isn't often that simple to get rid of
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching if you
require the assistance of an architect
to help you through throughout this
process simply jump on the website down
below in the description send me an
email and I'll be happy to help but like
I said that is all from me so I'll see
you next Monday